それで私の人生ですがというところで
私は死ぬわけはないという前提で生きているんですよ
人間は 死ぬんだということを思うことは全くないんです
例えば頭でああ まあ死ぬでしょうと言うのであって
その瞬間 その瞬間死ぬってことはありえない
それはそれから後で将来起こり得る出来事にするんですね
死の実感がないんです
我々は常に今ここにいるという実感なのです
実際 我々の心に何が起こるのかというと
今ここにいるという 何か見ても聞いても
味わっても 嗅いでも その裏で今私はここにいるという
だからずっと私はいる
私はいる 私はいるという実感で生きているんです
認識が変わりますよ だから人が喋ることを聞く
音楽を聴くと心がそれなりに変わりますけど
いつでも今人の話を聞いている私がいる
今音楽を聴いている私がいるという
ずっとこの私がいる 私がいるという実感だけはあるんですね
外のものについても 今ここにあるという実感なのです
外のもの 例えば今 このペットボトルを見る
あるんじゃない？ペットボトルが
だからあるという実感なんです
例えば花は今ここにあると目で認識する
花見えたということは
そこに花があるという意味なんです
我々にとっては 音を聞いたということは
そこに音があるという意味で我々にとっているんです
あるという言葉でとっているんです
そこは天道になっちゃうポイントなんです
頭で妄想するときも その瞬間で
その妄想概念が頭の中に実在するんです
そこで妄想するでしょう
昨日のこと  10年前のこと
あるいはありえないこと
変な妄想をしている時でも
その瞬間に自分にはそれが本当なの
本当の実在するんです
妄想って危ないのはそういうわけなんです
こういったこと まああるんじゃないっていうことでも問題が起こるわけじゃないんです
ただ天道だけで しかし
何か変なことを妄想している時
その瞬間で その自分にとってそれは本物なんです
例えば 10年前で人を言われたことを思い出したりして
その時怒ったならば今も怒れますよ
10年前のことを思い出して
またあの怒りがまた蘇ることもできます
それ  10年前のことだから
今怒らなくてもいいでしょう
もしかすると その人は死ぬ時
何か何か嫌なことを言ったかもしれません
それでカンカン怒ったと
それで死んで 10年も経っているのに思い出してやる
また怒るんですよ だから実際しないのに怒る
なんで怒るんですかね
妄想がその人にとっては実在しているんです
自分が瞬間瞬間で変わっていくプロセスであることは推測できても実感はありません
自分というものはずっと流れるプロセスなんです
これはまあ考えて あ なるほど
そうかなと頭で考えることはできますけど
実感がないんです 例えば
細胞がすーっと壊れていくんだとかね
血液が流れてどんどん体が新しくなっていくんだと
音が聞くたびに自分が変わっていくんだと
ものを見るたびに自分が恐ろしい勢いで変わっているんだと実感ないんです
自分がいる 自分がいるという天道だけです
アディコシ中だけなんです
ギャーギャーと言うと
あ なるほど そういうことかもねと思うことはできますよ
でも実感が出てこない
外のものに対しても 様々な原因で認識が起こるプロセスであることは
その原因は瞬間瞬間変わっていくものであることは実感できません
例えば映画を見ていると
映画というスクリーンでずっと光が変わることでしょう
でもそれは見えます ただ
映画を見えるんです 今もずっと変わってますよ
光が当たって 光が当たって
当たった光が消えちゃって
また新しい光が当たって
この画像を作っているんですよ
そんなものは見えません
我々に画像がある それで終わり
だから事実見えないという残酷な状態なんですね
ただそこにあるなのですね
我々には これが天道というんですね
あべこべというんですね
あるという言葉はあべこべなんですね
したがって 死の実感はあるはずもないんです
起こりませんよ 死の実感は
だって今いる 今いる 今いるだけでしょう
今いると言ったっても
10年前で言った自分の細胞 1個も今ないんですよ
もう完全に死んでる もう完璧に消えてるんです
ただ 自分の国の連中はね
私はここで生まれた人の人ではないから
元カネコレと言ってますけど
もう完璧に何ひとかけらも国のものは今ないんです
もう 20年も経っているんだから
日本に来て ひとかけらも何もないんです
しかし このあるあるあるあるっていう話でいくんだから
同じものだと勘違いするんです
だから私はもう 10年前の私は綺麗さっぱり死んでるんですよ
20年前の私はもう綺麗さっぱり死んでるんですけど
この死んでいくプロセスはもう実感できません
いるいるいるだけ実感できます
だからそこさえも天道
それから見解まで作る
だから私がいるんだと
魂があるんだという邪見まで作るんです
いるいるだけではもうまた邪見に行ってないんだからね
もうなんとかできますけど
邪見まで作っちゃうと
もうかなり手強いんです
死にたくはないという願望は強烈です
それから死にたくはない
死にたくはないと願望っていうのは強烈にはあるんです
それみんな死にたくないというだけで
なんでそんなに死にたくないの？だって死んだ経験もないし
死は実感もできないでしょう
実感もできないのに なんで死にたくはないと思ってますかね
だったら本当のことなんです
本当のことは死んでいるんです
生きるということは もう死なないようになんとか何とか何とか手を打つことなんです
だから我々はご飯食べても呼吸しても
その死の恐怖感があるんだからなんです
死ぬんです やめたら ご飯をやめたら
呼吸やめたら死にます
結局は我々はあべこべだけで
心の底はそれ知っています
だからその願望があるんです
死なないという前提で生きようとする
だからもうこれ怖くてたまらんですよ
ちょっとしたことで死ぬ
階段からだっても十分です
頭がどこかで打ったら終わり
で 道路をちょこっと渡ろうとしたところで
もう車にぶつけたらそれで終わり
ちょっとしたことで死ぬんです
だからこれはやりきれない
だからみんな安全対策として巨大妄想の幻覚を作るんです
死なないんだ そんなこと
死なきゃいけないんだということでもう生きているんですね
生きることを支えてくれるものは
何であろうとも良いもの
価値があるものなのです
だから私はすぐ死ぬんだから
俺を助けてくれる人っていうのはありがたいんですよ
だから我々はご飯作って作ってくる人のことをありがたがる
金くれるならば その人のことをすごくありがたいと思う
褒めてくれるならばありがたいと思う
生きることを支えてくれるならば
これは当然みんなありがたい
ありがたいと 良いものだと
価値があるものやと思うんです
しかし あべこべと事実は対立するんですよ
勝手に妄想の中で我は死にませんよと
私に金くれる人は大変親切な人やと
叱責する母親がとんでもない鬼やと
そういう風に価値観 価値判断して生きていたっても
事実は事実です まあ例えば今日は真夏ですよと
頭で妄想することは簡単ですよ
イメージして真夏太陽がピカピカ光って
みんな薄着で汗たらしながらもうもう水浴びをしたり
もうプールで遊んだりすることをイメージはできますよ
外出てみてください イメージと現実は違います
だから対立が起こるんです
私が思うから それこそ事実だという理屈は成り立ちません
だから私は死なないと思っているんだから
事実とはなりませんから
事実と自分の思いは正反対です
あべこべです ですから対立が起こる
そんなはずではなかったと
誰でも生きている上で
そんなはずではなかった
よく思っていることをこうであるべき
ああであるべきとかね
だから自分がガンだと言われたら
あれ なんでや また私は
と 何言うんですかね なんで私は？と
よくそういうことを思っちゃうんですよ
あの 昨日のテレビか昨日の前か
ちょっと 2日あたりですけど
あの ある韓国人のあの歌手の仕事が
歌手でいっても あの あれ
なんとかの歌 歌うでしょ
何て言いますか あれはオーケストラとかね
オペラとかね オペラ歌手で
あの男性なんですけど
ものすごい声で このアウトの声
ものすごい響く もう信じられないぐらい声で
これでヨーロッパでもものすごい
もう信じられませんと
この人の声はってぐらいかなり売れてるみたいです
若いし これで日本の音楽プロデューサー誰かがね
これ見て これ一度もそんな素晴らしい声を聞いたことがないんだと
その上驚くのは もうこれがアジア人だから
なおさら驚いちゃったと
それでその人は日本で日本で日本ではなんとかなんとかオペラとかやってもらったりして
そこでその人はドイツのなんとかのオーケストラとか
いろんなところで年間契約で歌ったりしていたんです
しかし ガンになっちゃったんです
どこかというと喉なんです
そこで歌えなくなっちゃったんです
それでガン手術をして
それは綺麗に まあ喉だから
もう声が出なくなった途端
もう発見できるでしょ
だからもう だからガンはなんのことなく
すぐそれ外国で取り出されたんですけど
音は出ないんですね でも本人はそれでも喋られますけど
歌えないんです オペラ歌手だからね
相当なもんでしょう 歌う時はね
それで底になっちゃって
もうもう歌えなくなって
もうなんとかお医者さんが喋れるようにしてあげたんです
しかし 日本のプロデューサーで音楽の人が
この人も若いんですけど
この人のことにも感動して
これは放っておけないと
で なんとかもう日本にいろいろお金を積んで来てもらって
京都大学のこの世界一流のプロがいるんですよ
教授が 音声に対して その教授に診てもらって
まあまだなんとか手術できるのかと
で その教授が世界的な権威で
今年テレビで見た去年ですけど
あの先生曰くのは これ喉の問題があったら
人の期待は喋られるようになったらとてもありがたいということやと
これは期待はね レベルはるかに超えてるんだと
オペラ歌手として歌いたいというんだから
まあなんのことなく喋れますよ
すごい綺麗な声で 手術あとはそこでいろいろあらゆることを調べて調べて
この人の喉にいろんな研究してね
まあ一応喋れますから
歌ってもらうんですよ
カメラ入れて それこそ声帯の動きは全部調べて
低い声はいくらでも出ますけど
高い声になってくると空気が抜けるだけで声は出ない
そこで声帯の一つはもう機能しない
もう曲がったまんまに
この教授の手術は声帯をいじらないで
声帯を囲っている骨の箱がありますね
そちらに穴を開けて骨を中に入れて
声帯を一緒に合わせておく
合わせて結んでおくと動かないように
それから高い声が出るために
この声帯の箱が動かなくちゃいけないんですね
だけどこの人は落ちたままで機能しないんだから
それをまた上げて結んでおくと
そういう何段階も分けて手術しないといけないんです
だからそこまで大変になったら考えないでしょうね
まあこれは人間の体っていうのを機械と機械だと思ってるんだからね
私はね とにかくそういう順番でやっていて
手術台で本人に手術しながらね
これ合わせなくちゃなんだから
引っ張って引っ張って結んで
糸で結ぶでしょ はい では歌ってみてくださいと
手術中です 本人が目を隠してありますけども
歌うんですけど 歌ったのは子供の頃
学校の国で 韓国で教会で歌った賛美歌なんですね
思い出すのはそれだけ
では歌いたく歌いたくなるのは
まあそれからもうまた訓練もして
いくらか歌えるようになりましたけど
元の声はまだまだ出ませんし
そのエピソードで私は言いたいのは
この その人はもう徹底した神を信仰している
キリスト教の韓国人はほとんど 90%キリスト教だからね
神様は信じていますけど
本人に癌になる場合は喉が狙って癌になるんだからね
本当に親切な神様 その人の人生そのものダメになるんだから
収入資源そのものがなくなるんだから
で それでも2年向き いろいろあらゆることをして
やっと一回あのもう舞台で歌ってくださいと
人々みんな出て行ったからとかね
もうでもその人はもうやっぱり歌えないんですね
プロとしてのあれ 気持ちもあるし
それでも仲間の前で一回賛美歌を歌って
それで終わって まあなんとかなんとか
で 韓国にドイツの契約も全部取り消してで
韓国に戻ったんですね
戻って教会に行く場面があって
教会の神父さんが まあもうあなたの歌は人間に響きますよと
このあらゆる苦しみを乗り越えてきたんだからとかね
また偉い説教で説得力ある話で苦しみを乗り越えて
そこまで成長したんだから
あなたが賛美歌を歌うと人々は感動するでしょう
当たり前なんですけど
それと神と矛盾でしょうと
それで本人が神様ありがとうございますと音が戻ってから言うんですね
音が壊してからなんで言わなかったんですかね
だから音が壊して癌にするのは誰でしょうかね
手術負けて音が戻ったことは神様のおかげであると
ものすごい論理的なんですね
あれこれやと苦労して
日本の方々の音楽関係の人々は時々お金を募金していたんですよ
それで音楽家の叔母さんたちも
私はこの前この歌を聞いた
聞いたことありますよとか言って
お金入れたらいいと それでみんな一斉に頑張って苦労して
本人も苦労して あらゆる苦労をして
やっと修理して人間の手に直してもらったのに
そのセクションは神に与える
何がと もうセクションは誰に負けるんですかね
本当に人間っていうのはもう
なんていう屁理屈かと
で だいたい我々はそんなはずがない
そんなはずがないと思っている
医者がこれはガンだと言ったら
あれ なんでまた私に限っては？と思っちゃうんです
いっそね 我々の頭では私は死なない
まあ私にはこういうこういうことをできるんだ
するんだとかね 私は来年
もう例えばオリンピックに出る予定だとかね
それでもうオリンピックに行く 1ヶ月半まで実況で残ったら
なんで私に限っては そんなのはもうわからないでしょう
瞬間瞬間何が起こるのかわからないんだけど
我々はそれはないことについて何も起こるはずがないんだと
私は死ぬはずもないんだということで生きようとするんです
だから怒り 憎しみ 苦しみ
悩みの底のない穴に落ちるんです
だから 例えば私はもう成功するはずでしょうと思ってやったら
成功しなかったら ものすごく苦しみに陥っちゃうんです
怒るんです 恨むんです
だから我々の心にある恨みやら憎しみやら悩みやら嫉妬やら落ち込みやら
あれこれとあらゆる苦しみの原因が
我は死なないという前提から作り出しているんです
現れているんです まあどうせ病気になるんだぞ
病気でどうせ死ぬんだいと思ってる人は
あんたがんですね ああそう
がんになってるの 面白いって
それで終わりますよ まあ別に
まあ別に自然現象だから
ということになりますけど
そうはならないでしょう
80歳でおばあ様であっても
亡くなったら泣いちゃうんです
別に だってあんたなんで泣くのか
80歳のおばあさんが寝たきりでしたけど
ずっとあと 80 80 年いてほしいんですかと
お見舞いにも行かないのに
東京で忙しいとか言いながら
死んだと電話がかかってきたら泣くんだから
もうどこまで頭がいいんですかね
だからその時でもやっぱり涙が来るんです
悲しみの涙が 亡くなったら
その場合でも死ぬはずがないという前提があるんだから
そうなっちゃうんです
それで他人と戦うでしょ
他人と戦う 自分と戦う
それで必ず負ける 戦っても戦っても
年取らないように戦っても必ず負ける
世界に対して戦っても
負ける 負ける 負けるっぱなしで
例えばイラク戦争でイラク人も負けっぱなしで
アメリカも負けっぱなしでしょう
お互いの人が毎日死んでるだけでしょう
誰も勝ちませんよ 負けるはずがないから悔しくなるんです
生きることは楽しいのだと
このあべこべで思う それは怒りの先頭があります
それから生きることってなんと楽しいだと
違うんです 生きることが不出来ているんです
喜び 快楽を得ようとする
だから生きていて 喜び
快楽を求めよう 求めよう
求めよう と これは生きる上でいっぱいやりますよと勘違いしているんです
しかし 自分自身も外のものも不完全ですから
満足に至らないんです
食べて快楽を得ようと思っても
自分の舌が不完全です
神経が不完全です 歯も不完全です
で 食べるものは不完全です
どうやって満足しますかね
例えば食べた食べるものがもしかすると美味しくできているかもしれません
だけど 自分の歯が悪くて噛めない場合は美味しく感じないんですよ
あるいは自分のハートか口の筋肉がものすごくできていて
食べ物は本当にあまりに柔らかくて
口に入れたら噛む前に溶けちゃって喉に入り込んじゃう
もう味わってないんです
とにかく不完全なんです
ですから 快楽を得ようと思っても満足に至らないんです
それ大きな問題です また悔しくなる
満足に至らなくなっちゃう
だから戦っても戦っても負けるでしょ
それですごい悔しくなるんです
では楽しくやろうではないかと
快楽を得ようではないかと思っても不満です
満足しません そうすると
そんなはずではない これはごちそうであるはずでしたと
高級レストラン 時々この間
日本テレビでそういう人々の文句を聞いたんですよ
ものすごい性格悪い旅館のことを番組で出てきて
高級レストランのハソで旅館のハソで行ったのに最悪でしたと
そういうこともありますからね
まあだから悔しくなるんですよ
楽しいはずなのにという
人生は楽しいはずなのに
なかなかうまくいかないと
限りなく幸福 楽しみ 快楽を求める羽目になる
ですから もっと頑張ろう
もっと頑張ろうと この間行った旅館は最悪でしたから
今度旅行に行く場合は
初めから徹底的に調べてやるぞということになるんです
かつそれか探すのが基本です
だから快楽を求めれば求めるほど満足するんじゃなくて
なおさら必要になるという悪循環が生まれてくるんです
快楽こそが正しいだとするんですね
それで生き物は 生きるものは快楽を得ることこそ正しい道であると思っているんです
嘘も盗みも おかしな行為も
殺生もごまかし 詐欺 騙し
戦争 何でもOKなんです
快楽さえ得られれば そんなのは何でもOKなんです
だからどこまででも落ちるんです
行為と結果の法則は 人に自分の希望で変えることは不可能です
この字じゃないと思いますけどね
そこで我々には行為と結果は変えることはできません
例えば 石を投げてこの蛍光灯を壊す
まあ壊したい 壊したかったんだけど
光があってほしいとは
その話にはならないでしょう
因果法則を変えることはできません
勉強はしたくない したくはないんだけど
100点取りたいんだと
それはもう成り立たないんですね
だから因果法則は自分の希望と関係なく起こることなんです
部屋の中に蛍光灯 1本しかないと
でもふざけて遊びながら
これどんな風に壊れるのかとかね
ガラスだから脆いでしょう
面白そうで 壊してやるぞと思って
男の子が蛍光灯を壊したり潰したりする
それはいいんだけど しかし
暗いのは嫌やと それはありえないんです
壊れたならば もうそれから部屋は暗いんです
だから結果 原因に決まってる
結果が起こるんです 自分の悪行為の生き方によって
なおさら不幸に苦難に陥るんです
ということは 生きることは正しいんだ
吾輩は死なないんだということで
生きるために何でもOKという生き方やってるでしょ
快楽ばっかり求める そうすると悔しくなって
なおさら快楽を求める
あるいは攻撃する 戦う
怒る 憎しみ 戦争までする
それが行為でしょ その行為
ちゃんと見事に適した結果が出てくる
何一つもいいことをしていないんです
快楽だけを求めることっていうのはものすごい悪いことなんです
それからとことん戦ってやるぞと思うことはものすごい悪いことなんです
だから私は死なないという前提っていうのは
人に悪行為しかさせないんです
私は死なないという前提が人に悪行為しかさせない
したがって どんどんどんどん不幸に不幸に不幸になることは
たとえ神が来たっても変えることができないんです
期待が外れたので さらに悔しくなるのです
さらに同じ道で戦うんです
そこで幸福になるだろうと思ってやったことで
すべて不幸になっちゃうでしょ
アメリカはむちゃくちゃ褒めてくれるだろうと
今反対しているこの国も
イラクが万々歳 自由になって民主化になって
アメリカ主義になったところで
世界が羨ましくてアメリカを褒めるだろうとあのブッシュさんが思ったんですけど
行ったんです 最初は でも期待通りにいかなかったんです
歴史でこれほど悪い人は生まれてなかったと言われる羽目になったんです
大統領のリストの中で最低最悪の人間であると
あの頭の悪いレーガンさんさえもそんなに悪いことしなかったんですから
この人は一応インチキであっても大学出ているんでしょうし
エリートの大学 だから期待通りの結果にならなくなると
なおさら悔しくなるんですよ
そうすると同じ道をまた
それがあべこべの結果です
だから このあべこべ思考で
我は死なないという考えで生きると
どんどん苦しみだけ膨張して拡張して
ひどくなってひどくなって続くんです
止まりがないんです あと
これで終わります 真理を知ると幸福と安らぎがあります
すべては変わる 無常です
生きるとは死つつであることですと理解すると悪順が破れる
だから我は死なないではなくて
生きるとは死つつであることやの
いわゆる生きるとは死ぬことです
死ぬとは生きることなんです
死につつあること  うん
うん だから我々は瞬間瞬間で死んでいく
瞬間 瞬間で生まれている
だから仏教は道元さんも同じことを言っています
生と死と死っていうのは同じ意味なんです
それで私はこの間も言いましたけど
この生老病死っていうのは 4つじゃなくて同じものなんです
例えば命は玉だと思ってください
玉 玉だったら同じ側面一つしかないでしょ
紙だったら裏と下ありますけど
ボールだったら  하나一つでしょ
側面が そちらに生老病死と書いて書いてることと同じなんです
ただ単語違うだけ 瞬間瞬間
我々は死んでいく それに成長していくんだとも言うし
年取ったとも言うし 瞬間瞬間変化していることに病気になったとも言うし
その流れが肉体の流れがストップしたところで死んだというだけ
そういうことで それが事実なんです
だから吾輩は死なないんだではなくて
我は死につつあると それが正しいんだ
理解すると あの悪循環
とにかく生きてやるぞと
生きるためなら何でもやるぞと
戦争でも何でもやるぞってことはなくなっちゃうんです
まあまあ どうったことはないと
どうせ死つつだから 戦うことをやめましょうと
それは落ち込むです 気楽になるんです
無理に挑戦しないことにするんです
無理に挑戦するということは
死なないために 年取らないために
病気にならないために挑戦しない
それはもう魚が泳がないために挑戦することと同じだから
それは意味がないんです
魚はそれよりは身を守るために
みんなと仲良くするために挑戦すればいいでしょ
無理に挑戦する必要はないんです
だから悪を犯せなくなるんです
私は死につつあると分かっただけで
自分から自然に悪いことをしなくなっちゃうんです
なんでまたそこまでやるの？と
帳簿をごまかしまでやるんですかと
別にいいんじゃないか
そこまでやらなくてもという気分になるんです
人を脅してまで騙してまで商売する
そこまで別にいいんじゃないですか
だから あの 死を知っている人は悪いことをしないことになります
自然に行う善行為の結果で幸福は流れるんです
そうすると自分が偉いことをやっているわけじゃなくて
普通に生きているだけ
しかし 悪を犯してないんです
犯せないんです 悪を犯さない人は善行しているんです
それで自然に幸福という流れが生まれてくるんです
精神的な病気も無知もなくなるんです
すごい精神的な病気に今までいたんだけど
それはなくなる 無知もなくなる
心は健全な状態になる
したがって能力は向上する
心が健全になったら 能力っていうのはいくらでも向上する
努力は実る あの５つの欲望
希望は叶いませんだけど
他の努力は何でも実る
心の汚れが消える 輪廻を乗り越えて解脱に達するというところまで行くんです
だから 我々の宗教的なのは
我々は死につつあるということを理解していて
そのもとできることなんです
それぐらい結果が出ます
それで今日の話は終了すると思います
あと 1時あります それで初めて死を乗り越えるということなので
解脱に達した人こそ死を乗り越えたことになるんです
で 終わりです